i was absolutely terrified there was a
long list of actors lining up to take on
the reigns of the leading character in
matt reeves the batman with its release
so close and so many cast interviews we
wonder how they land the parts we're
taking you on their journeys before they
began filming and why they were chosen
to be a part of the next batman film
number one robert pattinson jumped
through a lot of hoops to land the title
role in the batman but the main part of
his audition process trying on the suit
it's the size of your head that's the uh
the defining factor pattinson said
trying on the suit was not the easiest
part and certainly wasn't the most
comfortable either costume designers
pulled out all the bat suits from the
past in hopes he would at least fit in
one of them but unfortunately he
couldn't fit in one of them however this
is where costume designers shined mixing
and matching the helmets and bodysuits
of each one to see if any of them would
work kind of frankensteined it but
either one didn't really fit robert was
like goldilocks with them some were too
small for his head and others were just
too big weird considering he's already
pretty tall but they finally settled on
the best look for him george clooney's
bat head was the only one big enough for
him and val kilmer's bat suit just fit
like a charm trying to squeeze your legs
into this 30 year old foam costume
luckily pattinson was ready for the
screen test and as soon as he put on the
costume he went full on batman
number two zoe kravitz had to put in a
lot of effort to get the catwoman role
in this movie and she had to endure a
lot of anxiety throughout as well it's
scary it's intense it's intense she's
not a stranger to the audition process
but with the role of this caliber her
anxiety almost got the best of her after
busting through the initial stages to
get the attention of producers she
finally got to put on the suit and
perform next to robert pattinson they
asked her to take off her helmet and
deliver the lines simple enough right
not simple for kravitz because she just
got too caught up in that simple action
she recalled that awkward moment where
she attempted to capture catwoman's
sexiness but just couldn't accomplish
that with the helmet removal of course
she was able to get the part but this
moment definitely made it harder for her
yeah i'm trying to be like i don't care
number three if only zoe knew that she
was not alone during this moment and
that the fearsome batman was having his
own panic attack alongside her i felt
like i was still alive yeah that was the
case for poor robert as this was also
his first time saying a single line as
the batman we can understand being a
little nervous with the cameras on you
for the first time in a new role but he
really wasn't even shown during
kravitz's screen test it's hard it's
hard it's it was a really large role
robert was even leaning on zoe for
emotional support during the scene and
she really did do well considering she
got the part maybe it was just the
nerves of saying the lines but we can
also agree that zoe's acting skills had
a part to catch robert off guard and she
like didn't look nervous at all she was
kind of improvising and stuff number
four there are times when actors just
have a hard time getting into their
roles but for pattinson all he had to do
was put on the suit i still can't really
understand that it's even happening the
history and legacy of the costume can
really work wonders on an actor's
performance changing everything from
their body to their voice you put the
suit on and you have to speak in a
certain way robert accredits a lot of
his performance to his bat suit with the
way it gives him a sort of strange power
and this kind of feeling can rub off on
others specifically the cast and crew
people get freaked out by it when he put
on the outfit for the first time for a
camera test robert could see the
frightened look on everyone's faces and
him being such a nice guy this was a
little tough to swallow for him but
feeling this kind of frightening power
in the batsuit isn't a new thing a lot
of batman actors shared similar stories
of donning the cape there are no reports
yet as to whether pattinson added his
method acting approach to the role but
maybe the suit just did it for him has
such a kind of totemic power number five
the villains of batman are almost
endless and putting together the look of
colin farrell's penguin for the film
seemed a little lengthy too someone to
do the teeth someone to do the wig
someone to do that there's something to
do we sat and wondered when we would see
penguin for the first time in the
trailer second guessing who exactly that
actor was and that's thanks to the
film's makeup department who worked
tirelessly with feral to get the look
down right it just sparked my
imagination and continued to every day
that i went to work it wasn't as
difficult as most processes are for
initial makeup designs and it was also a
very big team effort colin recalled
having a very enjoyable time working
endlessly with the other artists to get
a look that works for both the actor and
the film it was so exciting and we were
all just on the same page all this work
helped mold his character and voice
something that can definitely take the
load off an actor's busy schedule we're
more than excited to see a little more
of his character when the film comes out
and thinking just how they were able to
make a very recognizable actor
unrecognizable
number six even batman can rock some
heels and this one apparently needed
them seems like such a bad idea you know
pattinson six foot height wasn't enough
for director matt reeves so they opted
for some stylish high-heeled shoes
instead pattinson found them a little
ridiculous with the seriousness of the
character but they were adamant about
using them so of course he obliged i
wanted to do a radically different thing
to all the other batman the full outfit
reveal looked so batman to us and all
the aspects of its design definitely
played out well in the end for his
character but if they were a little too
awkward for robert to wear we wonder if
they had extra rehearsal time for him to
practice punching bad guys in heels
it's a it's a quite unusual dance
number seven the world's greatest
detective couldn't figure robert was
donning the cows so early on but leave
it to a batman visionary to see right
through him i hadn't told a soul about
it dark knight director christopher
nolan snagged pattinson for a role in
his film tenet and to his surprise
pattinson had just got secretly offered
the role of batman a day before shooting
began robert was told to be a little
hush-hush about the role initially but
somehow nolan has a hand in everything
batman chris obviously has the inside
scoop christopher confronted him the
first day after robert told a little fib
about a family emergency to go screen
test for matt reeves though no worries
nolan was just as happy for him as
pattinson was getting the role and to
get a congratulations from one of the
finest batman directors in cinema
history must have really meant a lot to
him
number eight there was a short period of
time after ben affleck left the titular
role that every actor wanted in on his
replacement and for pattinson curiosity
came to him when he met with the batman
producer dylan clark for a non-related
discussion i saw in his imdb that there
was just rumored batman involvement
pattinson always had an affinity for
batman and always wanted to be involved
in a superhero movie meeting with the
producer was his best chance so he
decided to give him a little push
towards his direction to think about
casting him there's an opening there so
i kind of kept pushing and pushing with
an open-ended twinkle in clark's eye he
definitely saw robert as a potential
candidate for the role just that small
question from pattinson started a
cascade of persuasion and insistence
from him to finally snag the part number
nine a surprising initial choice to play
the villain role of riddler was jonah
hill he was actually in deep
conversations with producers before
dropping the part we really couldn't
imagine why he dropped such a title role
but we can be glad it landed in
award-winning actor paul dano's hands
hill does indeed have a very impressive
acting resume and there's no doubt he
wouldn't have made the role
extraordinary in the new batman however
with the look we've gotten of the new
riddler from the trailers we simply
cannot wait to see dano's take on it
these actors really put in a lot of
effort and desire to audition for the
batman and casting did a great job
picking them if robert pattinson never
rocked those high-heeled shoes and the
outfit would he have still been right
for the role did you have a favorite
audition experience from the batman
let us know in the comments